Now, I'm guessing is there could be 3 options.
And I'm going to walk through backwards to talk about why
they are all so vital to our chronometer that we want to make.
Even if I device the pit itself and does so in a consistent manner,
if we don't know how long those repetitions take, well what good is it.
If 10 ticks of our clock corresponds to 10 seconds or 15 or 20,
but we just don't know, well it's not a very useful clock.
Obviously, it has to be isochronous if one tick of the clock is one second
and the next is seven seconds, well again I use this clock.
And all of these required that something be happening over and over
at regular intervals, which means periodic.
Well, it would be nice if our clock could run forever without power.
If you know how to make a clock that does this, you just invented a perpetual
motion machine and send me the diagram please.
Now, what's really cool is there is a whole field of physics
dedicated to phenomena that meet this criteria, simple harmonic motion.
Underlying this field of study, simple harmonic motion is the concept of equilibrium.
So let's talk about that.